you guys it's been a crazy week in
america let's find out what happened
the cdc recommended this week that 28
million kids in the u.s get the
coronavirus vaccine that story again the
cdc recommended that all of nick
cannon's kids get the corona by respects
from them um
got a lot of you got a lot of kids i
mean what do you want that's a lot
i mean that was a joke but not
no he's got a lot of kids he's got a lot
of kids what do you have like
16 kids i don't know what is the number
28 okay everyone at home find out the
number tweet it at derek davis don't
i don't want to know everyone tweet
and include the subject hey terry you
were wondering how many kids naked it
has
here's the answer
thailand reopened its borders this week
to vaccinated tourists from 60 countries
no word on when the u.s plans to reopen
its borders
remember
remember
i remember yeah no i used to love
borders
loved borders come on come on borders
orders sorry all's we got is barnes and
nobles uh
barnes and nobles
gotta make black people gotta make
everything plural yeah barnes and nobles
cards and nobles yeah i'm going to
targets
got to get to the targets got to go to
targets
president biden met with prince charles
this week at the un's climate change
conference said prince charles i mean
wouldn't you want to know how dark the
baby was gonna be
[Applause]
he doesn't say it in an accident either
he doesn't he the accent falls off falls
off he's good second yeah
oh yeah i would love some tea but i
really wonder how dark that baby's gonna
be
yes
scandal of my life
it should not have been shocking that
shot my balls off yeah
really while president biden was in
europe this week let's go brandon
oh i'm sorry what was that
i said
i said let's go brandon oh who's brandon
you don't know
no
hilarious okay so there was this nascar
race last month where a guy named
brandon won and the whole crowd started
chanting something and the reporter who
was interviewing him thought they were
chanting let's go brandon
but really
they were chanting
joe biden
so now whenever conservatives want to
really stick it to liberals they say
let's go
brandon huh oh sorry i tuned out after
you said nascar race but
i'm glad you're having fun and good luck
to brandon whoever that is let's go
brandon
oh my god she said it i got her to say
it oh my god this is incredible this is
definitely going viral okay cool moving
on it's time for our next segment joe
biden
wait what
president biden was in europe this week
and boy is he
whether it's his struggling domestic
agenda has failed promises on climate
change or his meager defense of voting
rights the man is simply left and right
we elected him to do a job and he's
struggling to get it done which is why
we can all join together and say
joe biden
what is happening
we're doing a sketch
but how can you say that say what
joe biden oh it's easy
joe biden
you said it again aren't you afraid of
what
of joe biden what if he finds out you
betrayed him he'll ruin you i don't
think he has peacock
besides
look i hope he finds out maybe it'll
push him to actually do the right thing
but but i don't understand it to you
everything joe biden does is right isn't
he your savior my savior is black
[Laughter]
he's not your reason for living your
champion your ideal your son and your
moon your knight and your stars
isn't he the leader of your party don't
you owe him everything no
no
no
i owe him nothing joe biden's just a
dusty old fart who i voted for because
he was the best choice at the time he
seems nice enough but he's not my friend
compared to most presidents he's not
doing bad but he's a person i elected to
do a job and that's all i care about the
job not the person and if that means
sometimes i have to say joe biden to let
him know he could do better then that's
what i'll do
wow
you know this country be a lot better if
we all thought like that i agree anyway
it's time for our next segment donald
trump
traitors
[Applause]
okay moving on
footwear brand nike may begin selling
digital versions of its sneakers for use
in virtual worlds so be sure to pick up
a pair of air force one zero zero one
zero zero one zero
a texas woman was arrested this
halloween for allegedly pointing a gun
at a trick-or-treater so i guess
trick
international skeptics get
international skeptics day was on
tuesday
or was it
[Laughter]
and finally according to the new york
times people who feed deer in their
backyards may have given them the corona
virus
just what i need more bad news said
bambi
and that was the monologue did you guys
like it
that's what they say though they say
if you want to get an audience really
riled up make them think of a dead
cartoon mom
and remember that time you were all sad
all right
you guys that is just one of the many
fun things we have planned for you
tonight okay this all checks out looking
good excuse me can i help you oh hey
sorry to interrupt but i need to test
out this new voice recognition software
do you mind i mean i guess it's okay but
hurry up we're in the middle of a show
oh
hey
look at that
hey everybody
i'll make this quick
uh computer turn lights to blue
turning lights blue
oh whoa
that's cool well i doubt it'll
understand me and tarik though those
types of software are notorious for not
recognizing black voices oh you won't
have that problem with this one it's
from a company in england that claims
they've created a voice recognition
software that more accurately recognizes
black voices
yeah i read about that it's supposed to
be more accurate than apple or google oh
okay i want to try it computer turn the
lights to white okay sis i got you
turning lights to white and then we turn
it up ew
what the hell was that it's pretty cool
right
i thought this show would be a great
place to beta test it since it has so
many careful
so many very talented diverse people
good save tarik why don't you try it all
right uh computer play music what's good
fam oh
that's what's up you know i got you cuz
what you want some biggie young thug
losey burp
uh i was thinking more like harry styles
come on dawg i hear your voice
i know what you want to listen to my guy
playing r kelly no no no
no no no
here let me try computer play music
playing leonard skinner no thank you
computer girl right ain't nobody trying
to hear no damn leopard skin yard
leonard skynyrd you got it buddy i could
listen to some free bird hey man
i told you i ain't playing that [ __ ]
for you
now let me play some little baby dub
baby baby d or any of the rat babies i
got you what is wrong with this software
i guess there's still a few bugs to work
out you think
look i'd rather have it ignore me than
do whatever this is who programmed this
computer who wrote your code code
switchers
oh
don't say oh you don't know what that
means
i do not let's get rid of this thing
okay computer throw yourself in the
trash oh he said you're trash he said
you're trash
[Music]
you